this thing of ours why does the
godfather still ring true 50 years on
right and this is if you want to go to
this page to uh adam so uh
uh uh uh there there are the endless mob
movies of course but more important than
uh mere weight of numbers is the scale
of influence extended by just one
dynasty like a remarried parent the
godfather has
the original offspring two and three
then it has more good fellows the
sopranos in the course of the first film
corleone's tell
pacino uh pacino's michael he had hoped
his son would become a politician
instead politics became the godfather
where the rule we are ruled by men who
do
impressions of the dawn and kissing the
rain crosses anyways this movie went
from being a regular thing that came out
to now i mean it's crazy
presidents this is their favorite movie
politicians favorite movies
movies celebrities favorite movies it's
amazing yes
like you mentioned saddam hussein yeah
he had the scene queued up but he had a
big tv when i went through that she had
like crazy stories that's great tommy
saddam hussein
uh godfather with you no i didn't watch
it he had the scene up i didn't watch a
movie with him i went to his no he was
doing an arms deal with nadine khashoggi
and i brought the money over that's how
i went there he didn't open his doors
for me i was there for a reason will you
spend one-on-one time with him no no
just and hello goodbye and god was there
about an hour we had did you see what it
says about here with the capitalism
about the godfather do you read that
part which part is that
which is capitalism where are you okay
invisible power thrives elsewhere
because
another literal subject of the godfather
is capitalism coppola said it was his
biggest theme uh there omerta remains
the watch ward how many of us could
identify the head of the companies whose
products we buy how much corporate
uh uh skull uh scholar
duggary remains out of sight and if the
first lesson of the godfathers trust no
one the second is that each generation
ends up living the life of the one
before so it has proved 50 years after
don carlion the mafia is a husk america
itself is coming undone
but the bright right of the godfather
keeps being
handed down now as then our world is
strictly business
i know guardian article march 4. what's
the the
the
lineage of capitalism with the godfather
what are they basically trying to say
right there with the omarta
what would you say to that well i'll
tell you right now i i have a company
that i'm involved with called mj
licensing company
we own an exclusive license
for foods liquor first ride refusal
worldwide
we have seven liquors approved i don't
know how much food
we just renewed for another 17 years
in 73 countries
and
like saudi arabia
i'm going i mean i'm selling this stuff
50 years later that's why i always left
the last scene when michael says to me
no caller you're out of the family
business
now i own their business
i own jenko olive oil you know how funny
that is 50 years ago
if you if you go online and put it up
right now
go to quarterly owned fine italian foods
see what i own
coral you don't find italian foods so
online you can buy it
i sell gift packages all over the world
there it is hello
is that you hello
how about how much business does that do
every year
i'm actually curious how much i can say
that in this country but but me oh so
that's basically where is it everywhere
the djenko olive oil see jacob oliver i
own the can from the movie
that's the can
that when
godfather two
when when
janeiro went over and gave the old man a
draco
he brought the candy and he cut him up
because that's the guy that killed his
father
i own that
and do you see brando yeah
i made a deal with the brand-new estate
not meeting the company i don't want to
say makers then the irs is coming but
this company owns the worldwide rights
it's insane
so if you enjoyed this little segment
from the podcast click over here to
watch the entire podcast and if you've
not subscribed to the channel please do
so take care everybody
[Music]
you